Digamos que tenemos una solución en la que el
solvente es agua y el soluto es el alcohol que
consideraríamos apto para beber o etanol, así que
esta es nuestra solución. Digamos que es el etanol
al 10%, que es alcohol etílico, y que el resto
es agua. Y lo que queremos hacer es encontrar
una manera de conseguir algo que tenga 15% o 20
o 30% de etanol. ¿Cómo podríamos hacerlo? Bueno,
la respuesta radica en el hecho de que el etanol
y el agua tienen diferentes puntos de ebullición.
Por ejemplo, el punto de ebullición del etanol es
de aproximadamente 78°C, mientras que el punto de
ebullición del agua es 100°C, así que una mezcla
de etanol y agua va a tener un punto de ebullición
en algún lugar intermedio. De modo que podríamos
imaginar que podemos calentar esta solución más
allá del punto de ebullición del etanol, pero va
a hervir antes de llegar al punto de ebullición
del agua, y cuando esté hirviendo, debido a que
el etanol tiene un punto de ebullición más bajo,
la mezcla de vapor va a contener más del 10% de
etanol. Si pudiéramos condensar ese vapor entonces
tendríamos una solución con más del 10% de etanol,
y de eso se trata exactamente la destilación. De
modo que podríamos destilar con un artilugio
que se ve así. Al principio parece complicado,
pero luego, cuando entendemos lo que está
pasando, en realidad es bastante sencillo,
es exactamente lo que acabo de describir. Lo
que haríamos es poner la solución original aquí,
luego calentarlo. A menudo lo vamos a calentar
en un baño de aceite, es lo que vemos en color
amarillo justo aquí, porque el aceite no se
evapora fácilmente y puede distribuir el calor de
una manera uniforme. Y luego, si calentamos esto
hasta que la solución hierva, recordemos que va a
ser un punto de ebullición en algún lugar entre
78°C y 100°C. Vamos a tener algunas moléculas
de agua vaporizándose, pero esta temperatura, que
está más allá del punto de ebullición del etanol,
seguramente vamos a tener una mayor proporción de
moléculas de etanol vaporizándose. Esas moléculas
van a estar en forma de vapor y podrán entrar
en esta cámara que tenemos aquí. ¿Y qué es esta
cámara? Esencialmente le llamamos condensador,
así que a menudo vamos a tener el vapor separado,
pero vamos a hacer que el agua, el agua fría,
rodee este tubo, generalmente un tubo de vidrio,
algunas otras veces se utiliza aire frío para
enfriarlo. Entonces tenemos agua fría entrando
y dando la vuelta en el tubo, no se mezcla con
el aire dentro del tubo, y luego el agua sale,
pero lo que hace es bajar la temperatura en ese
tubo. Así que podemos imaginar que el vapor que
entra contiene tanto etanol como agua, pero la
proporción de etanol en el vapor es más alta que
la proporción en nuestra solución original, y se
va a condensar nuevamente en forma líquida. Luego,
simplemente se va a verter de nuevo en esta cámara
de recolección que tenemos aquí. La cámara de
recolección está rodeada de un baño muy frío,
a menudo llamado baño de hielo, para minimizar
la evaporación. Dependiendo de lo bien que lo
hagamos, tal vez esta muestra de aquí podría ser
etanol al 20% o etanol al 30%. Todavía habrá algo
de agua que suba aquí, se condense y luego vuelva
a bajar. Ahora, incluso si quisiéramos una muestra
más pura de etanol podríamos seguir haciendo esto,
podríamos llevarnos lo que recolectamos aquí
y calentarlo hasta su punto de ebullición,
que ahora será un poco más bajo que la primera
solución, porque tiene una mayor proporción de
etanol. De modo que tendríamos que hacer el mismo
proceso una y otra vez, y cada vez que lo hagamos
obtendremos una muestra más pura de etanol.
Si no queremos hacer eso porque es agotador,
se necesita mucho trabajo, y de hecho terminamos
con mucho material perdido a través de todo este
mecanismo, hay algo que podemos hacer llamado
destilación fraccionada. La destilación
fraccionada obtiene múltiples vaporizaciones
y ciclos de condensación a la vez para obtener
una muestra más pura. Y la forma de conseguir esas
vaporizaciones múltiples en ciclos de condensación
es agregarle algo al tubo para que el vapor se
condense aquí, una parte de lo condensado se
volverá a vaporizar y otra parte goteará. Es
probable que la parte que se revaporice tenga
una mayor proporción del destilado, lo que tiene
el punto de ebullición más bajo. Podemos tener
múltiples ciclos de esta condensación y
revaporización dentro de esta columna,
y así al final es más probable que tengamos
una muestra más pura de nuestro destilado.